- Hello.
Hi, good afternoon.
Welcome to STG 208, maximize
the value of cold data
with Amazon S3 Glacier storage classes.
My name is Gayla, I'm
very excited to be here
and I'm really excited to see you all
in the afternoon after lunch.
So, give yourself a pat on the back
for making it to your session.
Just by a show of hands,
how many folks are already using Glacier?
Okay, we got a few of y'all out there.
Good to know, good to know.
We built this session for
people who are new to Glacier,
for some folks who may be
occasionally use Glacier
or familiar, and we even have some stuff
for those archiving
storage pros out there.
So, got a good session for you.
You can think of this
session in three parts.
In the first part, for
those new to Glacier,
I'm gonna briefly cover why
your cold data is important.
I'm gonna go over the S3
Glacier storage classes.
I'm gonna talk to you about
getting your data into Glacier,
getting your data out of Glacier.
Then I'm gonna hand it over to Nitish,
who's gonna cover some new S3 storage
archive-related features.
And then we'll have a
quick demo for the pros.
All right, let's get started.
S3 has hundreds of trillions
of objects currently,
and one estimate out
there says that 70 to 80%
of cold storage of data
everywhere is cold.
What we mean by cold means it's
data that's rarely accessed,
it's sometimes stored for
months, years, and even decades.
And that's hard to ignore
because that amount of data
is growing every single day.
But what's interesting is
that the value of that data
is increasing.
Across industries,
we're seeing something
very remarkable happen.
Cold data isn't just store
and forgotten anymore,
it's now become a catalyst for innovation.
It's emerging as a huge
differentiating factor
for a lot of businesses,
and our customers are unlocking
all different types of ways
to use what was months,
what used to be considered dormant data
and turning it into
actionable intelligence.
So think bigger than storage.
Let's say you have a whole bunch
of historical handwritten
records and you wanna build,
use it to train machine learning
to recognize handwritten
data for those archives.
You might wanna derive new
insights for archived analytics.
Maybe you have a bunch of
financial or stock data
that you want to use to
build new application.
The opportunities are endless,
and our customers are
every day identifying
new opportunities for
this archive content.
And it's about turning
every byte of cold data
into an opportunity.
And that's why Nitish and I are excited
to go over S3 Glacier with you all.
We're both on the service team
and this is hugely important to us.
So let's dive a little bit deep
into what the Glacier storage classes are.
Now, if you've been around S3,
you've probably seen a
slide like this before.
But for the new folks,
let's talk about these storage classes.
Imagine a continuum where you're
balancing two key factors.
It's your access speed
and your cost efficiency.
On your left, we have our
frequently access data,
so it's ready for you in your
applications in milliseconds,
but it's at a premium.
And as we move right,
we're entering into
progressively cooler territory.
This is where your access
becomes less frequent,
but your storage costs are
going to drop significantly.
So let's break this
down a little bit more.
With S3 Standard, you're
getting that millisecond data
you need for your active, I'm sorry,
that millisecond access
for your active data.
And moving through S3
Standard and S3 One Zone
and frequent access,
you're already gonna start
seeing some cost savings.
Then as your data continues to cool,
you can move it through Glacier,
and this is where the real
magic for cold data happens.
You have Glacier Instant Retrieval,
it's for that data that
you need in milliseconds
that's still archived.
You have your Glacier Flexible Retrieval
for data that you need within minutes.
And then you have Glacier Deep Archive,
which is our lowest cost
storage in the cloud.
And here's the brilliant part.
As your data naturally cools
and as access patterns decrease,
you can progressively
move through these tiers
and continuously optimize
your storage costs
without sacrificing the ability
to retrieve when needed.
And you may ask though,
which storage class should you choose?
Think of this as finding the
right combination of cost
and retrieval speed.
For Glacier Instant Retrieval,
this is your go-to for data that's cold
but you need very quickly.
So, some examples of that
could be medical records
that are rarely accessed,
but when you need them,
you need them right away.
Or if any of you are in
the broadcast media space,
this could be archival cliffs
that have a tight deadline
that you have to pull in for a project.
This tier is also popular with those
who have compliance requirements
that require instant access as well.
Next, you have Glacier Flexible Retrieval.
And with Glacier Flexible Retrieval,
you could get something really cool,
which is free bulk retrievals.
This is for large scale data and analytics
where your timing is flexible,
backup archives where you have some time
and you can plan your retrievals,
and also historical records
that may need occasional bulk processing.
And our last tier, Glacier Deep Archive
where I mentioned before, is
our lowest cost storage option.
This is for your long-term retention
at the lowest possible cost.
It's storage for data
you hope you never need,
but you must legally keep.
And this, typically you're
measuring storage archive
in years and decades.
But how do you get data
into these storage classes?
For this, we have S3 lifecycle policies.
Lifecycle policies allow
you to transition your data
into infrequent access or
archive storage classes over time
as your data cools off,
and it can automatically delete that data
at the end of its life.
This allows you to
automatically control costs
based on known access patterns.
For example, let's say you have an object
that you created on day zero,
that's accessed very frequently
in the first 90 days.
And then after that 90
days, it's rarely accessed.
You can create a lifecycle policy
that automatically transitions your object
to Glacier Instant Retrieval
after that 90 days.
And if your application from then
needs to access that object,
it's available to it in
milliseconds and there's no problem,
it'll work great.
But let's say after 180 days
access is extremely rare
and we want to further
optimize our storage costs.
Our lifecycle policies can handle that too
by transitioning the object
to Glacier Deep Archive.
And then after that,
let's say you have a
compliance requirement,
maybe you're in the financial industry
and you have a requirement
of keeping data around
for seven to 10 years.
You can build a lifecycle policy
that will automatically delete that data
at the end of that time.
And we provide you with
the number of filters
that you can apply to
your lifecycle policy,
which determine which
objects that it will affect.
You can apply them to an
entire bucket if you need to,
but you can also apply
them to specific prefixes
or objects that match certain object tags.
You can filter by object
size, which is really great
for archiving because you typically want,
you typically want to avoid
sending a bunch of small objects
into archive, and you can
also filter by the number
of versions an object has.
So, if you want to avoid creating
a bunch of unneeded versions,
you can create a policy
that maybe creates one or two
and will delete everything else.
But let's say you don't
know your access patterns
or they're very unpredictable.
We have a storage class for that as well,
and that's S3 Intelligent-Tiering.
Sometimes access patterns
truly are just unpredictable
or unknown.
And S3 Intelligent-Tiering,
excuse me.
S3 Intelligent-Tiering is a storage class
designed for customers
who want to optimize
their storage costs automatically
when data access patterns change.
And it does that without
any performance impact,
operational overhead or
lifecycle fees or retrieval fees.
Intelligent-Tiering is a
cloud object storage class
that delivers those automatic savings
by moving your data between the tiers.
There's five tiers, three
of them are synchronous,
and you get those automatically.
They're available as soon as you sign up
and you have to opt in to
the two asynchronous tiers.
After you opt in,
Intelligent-Tiering, excuse me,
Intelligent-Tiering will choose
the correct tier for you.
So far, we've talked about why
your cold data is important.
We've talked to you about how
to choose your storage class,
how to get your data into a storage tier,
and how to get,
now we're gonna talk about
how to get your data out.
You've optimized all your storage costs,
so what happens when your
data is suddenly hot again?
Let's talk about restoration options.
The first question you might ask
is why are our customers restoring data?
Great question.
Let's look at some new and
exciting emerging patterns.
So you're sitting on a gold
mine of archived media files.
We're seeing our
customers breathe new life
into their historical content,
transforming decades of
old footage into fresh,
compelling content for today's audiences.
And when it comes to
backup and compliance,
it's not just about checking
regulatory boxes anymore.
Organizations are finding strategic value
in their historical records
and using them to track long-term patterns
and inform their future decisions.
But here's where it's
getting really exciting.
Cold data is rocket fuel
for machine learning models.
So think about it, you have
decades of historical data
training models to spot patterns
we never could have seen before.
Your archive data isn't just history,
it's your competitive advantage.
For example, let's say you are a company
that's working on
self-driving car technology.
Perhaps you need to train your model
and you wanna restore all your content
related to cars taking left turns.
You can do that with Glacier.
We are seeing a brilliant trend
where companies are
generating rich metadata
from their archive content,
making vast data lakes
searchable and actionable
in ways that they weren't before.
So now let's dive deeper into
how customers are accessing
their stored data in Glacier.
First with Glacier Instant
Retrieval, it's pretty easy.
It's the same GET REQUEST that
you would use for Standard
and Intelligent-Tiering
and S3 Infrequent Access.
You get the millisecond access,
and the trade off is higher
retrieval and API charges.
Customers often mention with
Glacier Instant Retrieval,
it's amazing for them because
now they're able to save
on their storage costs without
having to make any changes
to their applications.
However, if you have
retrievals that can withstand
some more times from
minutes to hours to days,
we can pull your data out of
Glacier Flexible Retrieval,
but that's a bit different.
You can lower your cost of storage
while also reducing the cost to retrieve
even large amounts of data
with Glacier Flexible Retrieval
and Glacier Deep Archive.
But with these storage classes,
they require a request
before data can be accessed,
and once restored, you
can call a GET REQUEST
on the same object key to get the object.
So, for retrievals from these
Glacier S3 storage classes,
Glacier Flexible Retrieval
and Glacier Deep Archive,
you generally have three steps involved.
First, you have to initiate a request.
Second, you have to check that
the restore has completed.
And finally, you access your data.
And I'm gonna take you through each step.
When you restore large
volumes of archived data
consisting of hundreds
and thousands and millions
and even billions of objects,
one factor to account for
is the time it will take
to submit all the requests
to Glacier.
Glacier supports a request rate
at a thousand transactions per second.
This TPS limit automatically
applies to all standard
and bulk retrievals requests
from S3 Glacier Flexible Retrieval
and Glacier Deep Archive.
So let's take an example, I did do math.
A thousand TPS, you can submit
10 million restore requests
in under three hours.
And using Standard Restore
from Glacier Flexible Retrieval
for example, you can complete all restores
in about six hours.
So that's, includes the three hours
to submit the restore requests,
and then three to five hours
to complete the restores.
And to ensure you get the
highest restore performance,
you can also rely on Batch Operations,
which I'll talk about in a bit,
and that'll help you maximize your TPS
and get automatic retries.
Now if you remember our second step,
that was monitoring the request
status for Glacier Restores.
For these restores, S3
will create an event
for restore initiation and completion.
And you can publish these
events to Amazon EventBridge
and you can configure that
to fan out to an SNS topic
or an SQS queue.
You can even have it
trigger a Lambda function
if you need it.
You can also configure
restores completion events
within EventBridge to send
events to an SNS topic,
which your application can then
follow up and subscribe to.
This will allow your application
to automatically proceed
to the next step such as a GET or a COPY
as soon as the object is restored.
And now we get to our final step,
accessing your restored data.
So once an object is
restored from Glacier,
your application can
access it like you would
any other object.
It's an S3 Standard now,
you can perform a GET
or access it any other way
that you would access an
object in a synchronous tier.
However, a tip, so remember this,
the restored data is a
temporary copy of the object.
To move it out of Glacier,
You can either do a copy
and place over the same key
or you can copy it to a new bucket.
If you're copying over
the same key though,
just keep an eye out for
adding an extra version
in case don't wanna keep an
additional Glacier version.
Now, I did briefly
mention Batch Operations.
The Glacier kind of works
like a freight train,
and if you know the batch,
we can do some optimizations on our side
to make things run smoother.
If you're getting less than
a thousand transactions
per second, that means the
request will take longer
to submit.
I've seen examples of
customers request around 25 TPS
and essentially increasing
their total restore time by 40x,
which is suboptimal.
But the good news is that
you don't have to optimize
your software or multithreading,
you can use Batch Operations
and that can dramatically
improve your restore experience.
Instead of fine tuning your
software, as I mentioned,
you can use Batch Operations
to automatically maximize your
restore request per second.
It can also do automatic retries
to handle any error failures
and with the completion report
that will signal any issues
with your job.
And then you create a manifest,
a list of keys you want to restore,
and submit to Batch Operations,
each manifest will be
associated to a single job
and additional jobs from there
will then split up your TPS.
All right, so we've covered, again,
the importance of your cold data
and how it can be an innovation
for your applications.
I talked to you about your storage classes
and how to pick the best one.
Talked to you about getting
your data into Glacier,
and I talked to you about
getting your data out of Glacier.
Now Nitish is gonna come up
and talk to you about some
new archive-related features.
Thank you.
(indistinct)
Whoa, I didn't.
- Thank you, Gayla.
Now you have seen S3 storage offering
and the pathways of getting the data in
and out of S3 Glacier.
Let me build on that foundation
and introduce two new capabilities
that we have recently added.
Each specifically designed
for archive workloads.
We actually, we are going to
talk about three capabilities,
so there is one that will be like coming
in Matt Garman's review keynote tomorrow.
So stay tuned.
So the first thing that
we are going to talk about
is checking the integrity of
your archived data at rest.
And the second thing that
we are going to talk about
is using S3 Metadata for quick discovery
of your archive content.
For each of these capabilities,
I'll address three questions.
First, what problems are we solving here?
How does it work and what
does it mean for you?
Let's start with the first feature,
new compute checksum
operation in Amazon S3.
Why this capability is so vital?
Because customers across domains
such as media and
entertainment, life sciences,
crime and justice, and
preservation institutions
perform periodic data integrity check
to make sure that the data is intact.
This could be the master
copy of an iconic movie
or it can be a historical artifact
like the Constitution
of the United States,
or this is something that is
required by the compliance team
or a proof that the evidence
has not been tampered with.
In all these cases, verifying archive data
is an industry standard.
Our customers asked us
to provide tools in S3
to help them do this, and that's
what exactly we have built.
Before I dive deeper into this capability,
one thing that I want to highlight
is that everything that
we are talking about,
checksum validation here
is completely optional.
S3 performs billions of
checksum operations every second
to make sure every date,
like every byte in transit
and addressed is intact.
But we also know that our
customers are already doing that
and we can provide a better
way of performing these checks.
So that was the intention
behind this feature.
But first, let's cover the basics.
What is a checksum that
we are computing here?
A checksum is a distal
fingerprint of an object.
In this example, we have three objects,
we are using the checksum algorithm CRC32,
and we have this unique
alpha pneumatic value
for each object.
Even a single bit flip
will result in a different checksum value.
Customers store original checksum value
on their media asset management systems
or in a checksum repository
as a source of growth.
And later it can be six months, two days,
few seconds after the
upload or after 10 years,
they come back and calculate
a fresh checksum of the object
that is in S3 and compare
that against the checksum
that is stored in their systems.
It's a way for them to prove
that the data remains intact.
S3 already provides a range
of capabilities during upload.
So when you upload an object to S3,
you can specify the checksum
algorithm you want to use
as well as you can provide a
pre-calculated checksum value,
which is optional.
You have support for six
checksum value algorithms,
CRC32, 32C, CRC64, MD5, SHA-1 and SHA-256.
For every upload, S3 calculate
CRC64 on the client side
and on the server side
to provide you end-to-end data integrity,
and only on the match
the request succeeds.
This works well for data in transit.
Now let's see how customers
perform data verification
for already stored data in S3.
Until now, verifying
checksum for data at rest
required two steps.
First, you download the
object which takes the,
which will have a compute call,
sorry, a bandwidth cost
or data transfer fee,
as well as some time,
it will take some time.
And then you spin up an easy to instance
or use your own infra to
calculate the checksum locally.
That means more compute costs, more time,
and added complexity.
For large archives, this
process can be cost prohibitive
or it will, it can be time-consuming.
We needed to eliminate the
step of downloading the object
and then calculating the checksum.
We wanted to come up
with an innovative way
to do an in-place read of the data
and calculate a fresh checksum.
And that's what we have done
with Compute Checksum Operation.
This is a new capability
in S3 Batch Operations
and it provides you a new
way to verify the content
of your dataset stored in
Glacier or any storage class.
You can efficiently
verify billions of objects
and automatically generate
a data integrity report.
You can use that to prove
that your data remains intact
over time.
This capability works
with any object in S3,
regardless of the storage
class or the object size.
Now whether you're verifying your data
for compliance reasons,
for digital preservation
or accuracy checks before
feeding the data into the model,
you can reduce the time, cost,
and the effort associated in that process.
And because it is built
in S3 Batch Operations,
you get automatic retries on failures
and detailed completion report in the end,
which you can use as the
data integrity report.
Let me show you how it works.
Creating a compute checksum job is simple.
It has three components.
First, you provide an object list,
also known as manifest
in S3 Batch Operations.
You can create a curated list
and then submit that as the CSV file,
or you can use S3 Batch Operations
automatic manifest generation service.
You can also use inventory report
and just feed that in as the manifest,
Batch Operation supports that too.
Second, you choose the checksum algorithm.
We already talked about the algorithms
that are supported in S3,
so the story is consistent,
everything that is supported on upload
is supported with Compute
Checksum Operation.
The algorithm that you pick
really depends on your business
or compliance use case.
So for example, if you want
something that is secure
and more compliant to regulatory needs,
you can go with Secure Hash
Algorithm like SHA-1 or SHA-256.
And if you need performance
and don't care much about
the compliance requirements
and all, you can go ahead
with CRC, CRC64, 32 or 32C.
And the third thing that you
specify is checksum type.
Checksum type, you can
provide a full object
or a composite checksum.
So if you're in media supply chain
or you're dealing with
third party providers
where you're providing your content
and you need to provide
a full object checksum
so that everybody's
talking the same language,
the chain of custody is maintained.
In those scenarios, you
can use the checksum type
as full object.
Whereas you don't have any
search needs, it's all internal,
your team knows what we are talking about,
you are dealing with large objects,
you want to perform
parallel checksum operation,
in that case, continue
or go ahead with composite checksum type.
And of course you'll need to
provide the IAM permissions
to S3 Batch Operations so
that it can read the bytes
and write the completion report.
That's it, these are the
three inputs that you need
and the permissions, and S3
Batch Ops handles the rest.
It will read the object, it
will compute the checksum
and provide you a nice
integrity report in the end.
And this is how the completion
report would look like.
It will have fields like bucket,
key, version_id, ErrorCode,
and ResultMessage.
Once the job is complete, you can use this
to validate with the
checksum that are stored
on your media asset management system
or checksum repository.
You can also use, let's say JSON parsing
and extract the checksum and the values
and convert this into a nice table,
the result message fields
that are available,
and use that for validation.
Additionally, you can use Lambda function
to automate this job,
let's say every six months
or one year if that is the need.
The best part is that you do
not incur any fee for restore
or retrieval.
Your data that is in
Intelligent-Tearing, it won't warm up,
and if it's in Glacier,
you don't have to restore
those objects from Glacier.
You pay a single fee of
0.004 per GB or $4 per TB
to process the data.
And that is consistent
across all storage classes.
Now let's move on to the next capability
that would be helpful,
and that is S3 Metadata.
Now this capability, this is
something that we launched
during re:Invent last year,
and we have made some
improvements to S3 Metadata.
S3 Metadata automatically
extracts metadata
from your objects and
makes it available to you
to generate valuable insights
using simple SQL queries
or natural language.
We believe that this
will fundamentally change
how customers manage and
extract value out of their cold
or archive data.
Let me explain the problem
we are solving here.
Here is an example, we hear
this from our customers
very often, that hey, we have a bucket
with millions of objects or files in that,
that they have archived.
They have tagged those
objects, so in this case,
we have tagged all the objects
either as Project Odin,
Loki or Thor, and then
few of them are untagged.
Some are in Glacier and
few are in S3 Standard.
And the customer's ops
team come and ask like,
hey, we want to move all
the data for Project Odin
that is in Glacier to Standard.
How much data are we talking about?
Today, there are multiple
options to answer that question.
You can paginate the
API requests like list
and get object tags and scan the storage
and calculate the storage
across storage classes.
Or you can use the S3 inventory
report, which comes like,
refreshes daily or every 48 hours.
And then you can use that
to answer this question.
But both options at scale
either delay in time
or are not easy to perform.
But we saw an opportunity
to make it faster.
And what if we could answer
this question in seconds,
we're writing a single query?
And that's exactly what we
try to do with S3 Metadata.
It is a fully managed service
that automatically captures
all your object metadata
tags, object storage class,
object size, everything that
you get from the head object
and store that into a
queryable Apache Iceberg table.
No APIs to call, no inventory
reports to wait for,
just instant SQL queries.
We launch S3 Metadata
at re:Invent last year
with starting with journal table.
The journal table captures
every change to your bucket
in near real time.
Puts, deletes, metadata
updates, tag changes,
all of them are captured in journal table.
It is your complete change
of logs of what's happening
in your bucket right now.
In July this year, we
added a new capability,
the live inventory table.
It shows the current state of
every object in your bucket.
It backfills all your existing
data when you enable it
and it refreshes every hour.
Both tables are read-only
and fully managed by AWS,
and you can think of them
as your authoritative system
of record for everything in your bucket.
Now, here is where it
gets really powerful.
You can query these metadata in two ways.
First, through standard SQL
queries using Athena, Redshift,
SageMaker Unified Studio,
any analytics tool that
supports Iceberg tables.
And second, through natural
language using Amazon Q, Kiro,
or any agent that you're using
with supports MCP server.
Here are a few examples that we tried.
First, to learn about storage usage,
the question that we ask ourself,
how much data is in
Glacier for each project?
Now you can simply write a SQL query
and it will give you the snapshot of that.
Second, you can also
identify all the objects
that were untagged so that you
can classify them properly.
And lastly, you can
also use it for auditing
the journal table to track
what data was deleted,
who deleted it, when delete,
like when was it deleted
and from where?
And just recently, we
added MCP server support
for S3 tables, which means you can connect
your AI assistants like
Claude, custom agents, Kiro,
directly to your metadata tables,
and interact with them in plain English.
That is really powerful because
it democratizes the access
or insights generation
from your archive data,
whether like you don't
have to be a data engineer,
data scientist, like anyone
from your team like finance,
ops, compliance team, they
can just write their questions
in plain English and MCP server
will convert those questions
or the agent can convert
those questions to queries
and extract the insight
out of the archive data
and provide them as something
that is like a summary
or easy to consume.
And now let's move on to the
next section, which is a demo.
So I'll quickly try to figure
out the logistics here,
so gimme a second.
So for a moment, let's assume
that we are space tech startup
and we are building an
autonomous space vehicle
and we are using the images
available from NASA and videos
to build a space simulation model
so that we can train how the vehicle,
how to navigate through obstacles.
These images are valuable
for training the data,
but we need to verify the
integrity of these objects
before putting them or feeding
them into those expensive GPU
compute thing that we need.
So for that, we are going to
focus on three things today.
We are going to use the inventory table
to find all the objects that
are related to Project Odin,
which is our code name for our,
like autonomous space vehicle project.
Then we'll calculate the
checksum of these objects,
and then we will use Kiro to
compare the completion report
with the original checksums
that are added as tags.
So...
Okay.
So here what we are doing.
One second, this is still not working.
Okay, so we'll go to this bucket
re:Invent storage 208 demo,
where we have hundreds
of images and videos
that we have downloaded from NASA website,
and they're stored across
different storage classes.
Few of them are in
Glacier Instant Retrieval,
few of them are in Standard.
We'll open one of them
and just look at the object properties.
We'll scroll down, we have
tags that is attached to it,
so SHA-256 checksum
algorithm that was computed,
the time when this object was created.
The checksum timestamp.
Project name as Odin.
And baseline checksum or the
original checksum hex code.
So all these are added to the object
and we have added that to most
of the objects and kept them,
few of them untagged intentionally.
Now, our plan is to use inventory table,
live inventory table,
to query all the objects
that are associated to Project Odin,
and create a list of that
that we can feed into Batch Operations.
So what we will do, we'll go to query
and we'll use live inventory table,
use SageMaker Unified Studio
to query our inventory table.
And we need to make sure
that we tweak the query
in a way that can be used
with Batch Operations.
So...
Yeah, so we need bucket and key,
and then we need to add a WHERE
clause where we are talking,
we are adding the WHERE
clause where object tags
have project name as Odin.
And then we'll run this query.
So, we have 25 files that are
associated to Project Odin.
Now let's download the CSV,
and let's see the values once
before fitting it into
S3 Batch Operations.
So we need to remove the first row
so that it matches the
format that is supported
in Batch Operation intake
process, and then save this file.
We'll save this as odin_manifest_v2.
Now let's go back to our
general purpose bucket,
S3 bucket that we had.
And we have created one more bucket there
for S3 Batch Operations jobs.
So here we have two buckets,
one for storing the manifest
and another one for providing
us the destination location
to get the results from Batch Operations.
So we'll upload the
odin_manifest_v2 to this folder,
then we go back and look at.
Okay, I think we are good here.
So this is our, this will
be our result location
where we'll be storing the result
from compute checksum job operation.
Now we'll create a new job
and we will use the existing
manifest that we just created,
which is stored in our
batch_manifest folder, v2.
Oops, CSV.
We will select compute checksum operation,
that is the new one.
Checksum type as full
object, and SHA-256 algo.
This is important, we need to
acknowledge that this report
can be accessed by the bucket order
because the completion report
will have checksum value
which is off the plain text data.
So that's important to acknowledge.
Then we provide the destination location.
And now we will just add the
permissions for IAM role.
We have created S3 batch
checksum role for this,
and we'll submit the job.
We will run this job,
and we will wait for it to complete,
which can take few seconds.
Meanwhile, just good to known info,
we have added automatic
manifest generation capability,
which was available through
Batch Operations API
to console as well.
So you can use that
for generating manifest
if you're trying it by yourself.
Should be done any moment.
Okay, so the job is complete.
Let's go back to our folder
that we created for batch results.
F2e9.
We'll go to the results.
And let's open it to see how
does the output looks like
in the completion report.
So this is how you get
as the result message,
this column is a result message,
and it has the checksum algorithm SHA-256.
The checksum type, full object.
The checksum value, both
in Base64 and hex code.
Okay, after this, we will
use Kiro to compare this
with the values that are stored on,
with the objects tags as tags.
So, we are using the Kiro CLI,
and we want to specify that
validate project Odin checksums
using the output of S3
Batch Operations job,
and then provide the link
or S3 UI for that CSV file
that we just got from Batch Ops.
It has created a Python script,
and all the 25 objects that
were related to Project Odin,
it validated that they match the checksum
that are stored as tags.
And with that, we conclude the demo.
And I want to summarize our
session with few key takeaways
that you can keep in mind.
So the first is, with advancement in AI,
archived data can be the
differentiating factor.
And S3 provides you
multiple storage options
curated for your specific business needs
in terms of access pattern
or storage time or the cost.
And finally, we are adding
new capabilities in S3,
such as compute checksum
operation or S3 Metadata
that can help you easily
manage archived data
at the same time, extract
more value out of them.
And with that, we would like
to conclude this session.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, please complete the session.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)